J'espère qu'on se souviendra de moi pour mon travail
sur les trous noirs et l'origine de l'
univers, pas pour des choses comme apparaître
dans Les Simpson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne te sens pas
mal  d'entre nous peut être le plus enfantin
même vous le savez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je crois fermement que nous devrions commencer à
chercher des planètes alternatives pour une
habitation possible nous manquons d'espace
sur terre mais nous devons briser  à travers
les limitations technologiques nous empêchant de
vivre ailleurs dans l'univers
[Musique]
Je pense que ma célébrité a beaucoup à voir
avec ma condition les gens sont fascinés
par le contraste entre ma
faiblesse physique mais l'ampleur des
problèmes auxquels je fais face
stéréotype d'un Feliz handicapé même si
je ne suis pas un génie comme Einstein